les dangers du cancer de la peau sont en
augmentation au canada on a un
diagnostic deux fois plus qu'en 1997
énorme juste pour vous donner un exemple
demain indice uv dans la région de
montréal deux sets donc élevées le
soleil qui est de plus en plus dangereux
michel rochon sera avec nous mais
d'abord voici ce qui nous a préparés
sylvain poissant est un survivant du
cancer de la peau le plus agressif
le mélanome il y a huit ans on n'avait
aucun espoir pour lui grâce à un
traitement expérimental aux états unis
il est encore vivant mais le mélanome
est un cancer qui se propagent la
maladie est revenue au médiastin revenu
au cerveau suite à des opérations ils
ont été capables de resserrer est là
depuis mai 2012 c'est présentement au
foie et je suis suivi là ici à l'octave
juive de montréal
la surexposition au soleil est à blâmer
les indices uv au canada est à la hausse
il se compare à celui du sud
l'autre source du v est artificielle la
mode des salons de bronzage fait dix
victimes
quand martin provost qui a dû faire
enlever eux mais là non mon message
auprès des jeunes s'étaient toujours pas
en fait qu elle lorsque vous allez dans
les salons de bronzage c'est un peu
comme aller dans un cercueil qui
malheureusement sont permanents le
cancer de la peau est devenu le plus
courant au canada
les cas de mélanome ont plus que doublé
depuis 1990
résultat les pactes économique de tous
les cancers de la peau se chiffre à plus
d'un demi milliard par année
d'où l'importance de la prévention au
niveau de la prévention de faire des
autos examen un peu que les gens pour au
front pour le ce1 s'examiner la peau et
s'ils détectent de coin de façon très
casse ça fait toute une différence au
niveau du prêteur pronostic c'est à dire
sur la survie des personnes
ces nouvelles données sur le cancer de
la peau font partie des nouvelles
statistiques pour l'ensemble des cancers
cette année il y aura plus de 190 mille
nouveaux cas de cancer au canada et plus
de soixante seize mille décès une
augmentation compte
tante attribuable au vieillissement de
la population et à la croissance
démographique chiffres dans votre
reportage 76600 des serres où ils se
situent le cancer c'est toujours très
sadir patrice et c'est peut-être la plus
grande de justice sur la terre nous
mourrons tous au canada un quart de
million de personnes décèdent à tous les
ans donc sa place le cancer environ 30%
des décès c'est beaucoup plus que les
maladies cardiaques sont environ à 20 %
donc on se rend compte que le cancer
prend grande partie fois ci on a un
tableau pour le montrer on sait que le
diabète c'est juste 3% l'alsace -2 6%
donc grosso modo on se rend compte que
cette maladie là un fardeau à la fois
personnelles économique social et pour
le système de santé très difficile à
gérer
donc vous dites deux canadiens sur cinq
touchés au cours de leur vie cancer au
canada c'est un tableau au canada ce
week-end
mora et 81% des cas touchent les 50
bon ça c'est le deuxième tableau en fait
oui depuis 88 126000 voyant on le voit
le premier que je voulais que je vous
donnais alors ça on voit la tarte on se
rend compte que finalement il ya plein
d'autres mais le 10 mai le cancer prend
le groupe le gros de la place faut dire
que c'est une maladie de vieillesse en
eux ont les buts en tout 80 près de 90%
des gens qui en souffrent ont plus de 50
ans la bonne nouvelle patrice c'est que
depuis 1988
il ya comme une inflexion dans le nombre
total de décès évités 126 mille décès de
moins que prévu
tout ça à cause dans le cas des hommes
du tabac ou là les politiques de danty
tabagisme ont fait leur effet et dans le
cas du cancer du sein la la prévention
le diagnostic et le traitement ont
amélioré énormément le sort des femmes
24 mille femmes de moins que prévu sont
décédées de ce cancer donc des bonnes et
des
ayant à coeur et qui attend tous voila
moi ça me fait plaisir pas prise enfin